So, why do we celebrate Valentine's Day and how did it start?
It's believed that Valentine's Day was started in Rome...
...during the reign of Emperor Claudius II.
Claudius made weddings against the law.
Believing this was unjust, a defiant Roman priest named Bishop Valentine,...
...would secretly marry couples in his church.
Claudius found out, and Valentine was sent to jail.
His execution was set for February 14th.
The jailer's daughter would bring Valentine his food, and soon, they fell in love.
The night before his death,...
...Valentine wrote the jailer's daughter a love letter...
...and he signed it, "Your Valentine."
Ever since, February 14th has been a day that we celebrate love,...
...and we show the people in our lives just how much we adore and appreciate them.